you think you don't you don't think most
guys have no i i agree i just feel like
you can
for example you can have a girl that
you're like that's your girl
and you can just
you can be with anybody like it doesn't
matter with
that's the point that i'm making like
yeah i agree with you oh okay yeah
like yeah like it don't matter it could
be it doesn't work you can be she can be
old young
victims like any it don't matter like
it's just for that moment yeah cause i
think when a guy sees a girl that he
finds attractive without even knowing
her name if she was like
yo i'm gonna come to this cupboard right
now nine times out of ten he's gonna say
he'd be like yeah but when a girl sees a
guy that's attractive even if she's like
oh he's really hot
a lot of the time and correct me if i'm
wrong ladies but i feel like a lot of
time you'd still be like even though i
would have said you i kind of still want
to know if you're a decent person before
i do it's more like i don't want to
catch anything
like i'm not trying to run bad std and
you can't have kids so i'm not trying to
yeah i don't know please please have
please please have protected sex yeah
but you can see there's still [ __ ] you
can catch with protected sex yeah for
sure but but me and i just feel like if
a guy was coming up to me and asking
that i'm like how many i can't be the
first yeah
i mean i mean let's let's put this into
context of real life
how many times have women come up to you
and gone do you want to come with me
into this back alley anyone has that
ever happened to any of you guys how's
it going not bad earlier no but really
openly you've never had a conversation
and they've propositioned you straight
off the bat has that ever happened to
any of you guys not like the first thing
she said but within like a couple of
minutes only once
the one i've got was um they would say
it but very s in a certain way so i
remember one time yeah girl was like oh
do you want to come back for cuddles
[Music]
that's that's the line
yeah so yeah it'll be very so it won't
be like guys what are like so we're
telling me
yeah yeah no i think guys the way guys
approach a guy in that manner is
different to how a woman approaches a
guy in a manner if a girl approaches a
guy in the same way sometimes he can put
you off but you're like
that was a bit too easy right okay
there was nothing for me to work with
like it was just
take it
yeah
see i asked that because from a female
perspective my concern is more the
safety of the fact i don't know who you
are
and it's less about that's true it's
it's less about the fact you've
propositioned me openly for sex and more
about the fact you could hurt me
physically yeah yeah i don't i don't
know you
and also i think it's another thing of
intimacy right so much of sex for me is
intimacy i i couldn't sleep with someone
i'd never even had a conversation with
who i knew i didn't click with because
how can i be vulnerable with this person
first of all like the best sex i've ever
had has been with someone i've either
been in love with or i've been able at
least to be intimate with but you know i
already know them we already know we've
probably already had i'm a very open
person in case you can tell um so i'm
able to have a conversation with the
person i'm about to sleep with or i am
sleeping with about what i like what i
enjoy and if someone propositions you
straight off the bat yeah yeah okay like
the chances of it being good are quite
slim because they don't know who you are
they don't know what you like they don't
know what you enjoy you've not had any
conversation about consent
so i i think that's also i think that's
another thing guys what about you with
only fans would you date a girl with
only fans
not seriously no not seriously no no
no i wouldn't sound sorry even though
even though you could understand getting
on it
even though you said you won if you i
get it but i don't think there's a any
guy that would consider himself like a
proper man that would
wife
yeah that old wife
um
a girl that's unonly fans like that
see i feel like you have something to
see here give her the mic
give the girl the
that's strong words um
no no just more this thing about uh what
what's what is a proper man what someone
who doesn't
uh yeah i guess to do with a man with
standards
and i think it's like important to like
have standards and we always tell men
where they can't have standards
i think it's important to have standards
but i think that's i don't think again
someone's numbers is a reflection of
their standards or what someone does for
a job but there's there's research that
shows that more of the more partners
like the woman has the less likely she
will be happy in the marriage
and the like the there's higher rates of
depression like there's a lot of things
that that are negative that are linked
to the more people you sleep with so
so so so can like how is it
bad for a guy to say i don't want to
deal with that because that's just a
standard he has okay the thing i would
challenge with that how big are these
studies and also you cannot isolate
these all of these people have not had
the same life experiences so you cannot
isolate just the amount of people
they've slept with the the control
variables are slim but don't
i agree with you like that's that's
where their discernment comes in but
like i don't i don't think there's
anything wrong with the guy saying like
like that he wouldn't date someone
that's on ole miss oh i i um yeah we
we've had this conversation as well i
said again i'm completely i can't make
you sleep with anybody i can't make you
go yeah absolutely what if you had a son
or a brother like you you really would
encourage them to like date someone with
an old hands it's not even a thing of
encouragement i'm neutral i would
encourage you to not be prejudiced i
would encourage you to view someone for
who they are as a person and i think
what you do for a job and who you've
slept with it's completely irrelevant i
think it's about him so what if he's a
criminal the guy so if a guy if a guy is
a
a criminal and he has a past of like
well it's robbing yeah sex offenses like
you don't think your actions show who
you are oh and what kind of yeah but
again that's not to do with the fact
that he slept with women that's to do
with the way again like that's i think
that's a complete that's well that's so
left but i think but i think no but it
it does because a girl that's slept with
more
men like i think the the issue is
ensuring paternity they're worried that
when in the relationship she's going to
do the same thing because that's her
habits the last couple of years the same
way that like if a girl is looking at a
guy and he's cheated in every single
relationship he's been in like that
that's your habit that's what you do
that's who you are as a person okay but
i think sleeping with lots of people
doesn't equate you being a cheater i
think so when you say about a guy can't
guarantee paternity okay but if she's
someone who slept with a lot of people
but monogamously
then the trend is she slept with a lot
of people monogamously so it's like okay
she's only sleeping with you
monogamously we're talking about
oh so so that's what we're talking about
like he said he like his he said that he
like a proper
like man wouldn't date a girl with an
all right should i
shall i tell you what i think it is
correct me from wrong right
is i think
the thing that i think sometimes girls
don't understand
about men
is that respect is very important
and respect amongst other men
especially men that you consider your
peers who you value men you look up to
men who look up to you is very important
and
if you're a guy and you have
committed and invested yourself
in
because thing is there are plenty of
women who may have great qualities as
the girl who has an advance but they
don't have an owners does that make
sense so i think if you as a man have
choose have chosen to commit and invest
yourself in
a woman that you feel doesn't
give great respect to you because your
partner is a reflection of you who you
choose is a reflection of you
then that does play a part in him
thinking okay is this somebody who i
want to represent me to the world does
that make sense so it i think you know
like chris you said your name right yeah
right and you're nigerian in it yeah so
i'm nigerian so respect in our culture
is huge